il l'a débat qu il y en a un avec des
insectes 1 avec autre chose et un avec
autre chose
vous allez devoir aller dans le bac
piocher une question du bac
si vous répondez bien mélanie repartira
avec un magnifique cadeau au jour pour
mélanie notre téléspectatrice je vais
prendre pour ce premier bac pour aller
chercher le premier papier balles et les
védrines non mais je vais pas le clodia
tagbo vita et alors mais c'était
chroniqueur télé souffrir à ozu pour
mélanie d'accord si vous devez piocher
une question du bac et ensuite y
répondre d'accord ou non à trois
questions
allez-y d'arrêter de regarder le oui
vous le mettez la main arrêter la sambre
à des niveaux bas monde a dit on y va on
sent oui on y pense mais sa mort ça mais
dans sa mort pas du tout aller soleil
arrête c'est pas la première et pas
choquer mais nadal et il ya plein de
questions à l'aise il faut que ces
questions et réponses sont mélanie on va
tous faire très bon cadeau à mélanie
[Musique]
aussi le père à tout le monde
quel était le prénom du philosophe
allemand nietzsche de chaque fonds 17 h
alors je vous donne trois mois pour
subis dit me el mout jean rachid où
friedrich chez moi près de régime
[Applaudissements]
ça porte à 15 mètres de haut il y avait
des certes rien alors on y va au bénin
fait patate rigide se sent que ça bouge
à des prix bas mais ça c'est le jeu on a
refait sa vie des insectes ici c'est
jeff chef jeff orr lui prendre un truc
comme ça mais oui les pointures de rien
il a dit il ya des objets saisis levin
il ya des crocodiles chez lui je peux
pas je te jure je peux pas aller bellac
pas le faire je ne peux pas mais la mp
toi
[Applaudissements]
temps
aulas
alors merde
de quel jeu c'est pas ça de quelle
fleuves français le tarn est il un
afflux de quelques clubs français
oui le tarn et tarn affluence à vous de
répondre bah oui faut se démarquer
notamment le tarn et garonne dacquois
lagarde le la garonne ne gardent
beaucoup différent de la garonne fouet
la gare en gare la garonne c'est une
bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
k
non
cadets mathieu fais pas ta frigide
[Applaudissements]
non alors bon je crois pas que ce soit
des personnes mais je regardais non
c'est pas des chars ont écouté ça
ressemble à des serpents ça ressemble
oui c'est vrai ça ressemble à du sa
ferme échapperait où s'achèvera qua non
non non non humains jeu une fois surtout
fait valoir vous êtes vous savez quoi je
vais faire quelque chose que je ne fais
jamais je vais prendre quelqu'un du
public pour vous remplacer mais c'est
moi tu nous entends ma grande gueule a à
elle à kader khadr non mais juste se
pressent à la moye au fait c'est vrai
voilà moi je me sentais j'ai regardé
récupérateur oui ah sinon qu'ils veulent
je la vole et anna merci mesdames venez
nico tu vas devoir jouer pour mail
mélanie qui est une collègue à toi
puisqu'elle est aussi thaliana l'habitat
liège
si tu vas devoir piocher une question du
bac et y répondre tu es le bac
oui tu me manques non non le 100g le
pays forçant pas du tout pas dit michel
aulas la mets ta main
j'avais touché le japon
non c'est rien ça tu vas du raid alors
non ça c'est pas une tête à cet instant
va va là bas va là bas la banane vers le
fond là-bas que maintenant bien vers le
oui si on était plus facile je suis là
je bosse voilà voilà celui-là voila
voila je suis gentil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez de quoi la peau attendait 6 10
j'ai eu de la peau de sacs par la famine
et isabelle morini bosc